it is my great pleasure to introduce the
keynote speaker for this evening dr.
Mark Zandi mark gave a great informal
lecture to our students last year mark
is quoted in The Times more than any
economists that I know and is actually
sort of the nicest economist I know in
many ways so mark is the chief economist
of Moody's Analytics where he directs
research and consulting is a trusted
advisor to policymakers and an
influential source of economic analysis
for businesses journalists and the
public mark is frequently testified
before Congress on topics including the
economic outlook the merits of fiscal
stimulus financial regulatory reform and
foreclosure mitigation mark's research
interests include macroeconomics
financial markets and public policy his
recent research has focused on the
determinants of mortgage foreclosure and
personal bankruptcy analyze the economic
impact of various tax and government
spending policies and assess the
appropriate policy response to bubbles
in asset markets mark is the author of
financial shock an expose of the
financial crisis and his forthcoming
book paying the price provides a roadmap
for meeting the nation's daunting fiscal
challenges doctors Andy received his PhD
at the University of Pennsylvania and
received his BS from the wharton school
at the university of pennsylvania we
forgive him for those affiliations and
we very much welcome him on the stage
dr. Mark Zandi thank you very much thank
you very funny
thank you Misha it done can you hear me
does that work hear me okay good I want
to thank bichon for the opportunity to
be here columbia as well it is a
pleasure I am a little surprised he gave
me two hours to speak though nothing
worse than an economist for more than
what do you think 25 minutes okay I'll
speak for 25 minutes and then we'll turn
it back to you to where you want to go I
also want to take my daughter Lily for
coming out with dad I knew that took a
bit of courage but I'm glad she's here
glad she's here she's going to hear
about three speeches in the next couple
of days and I promised her that the
forecast would not change no bichon I
was trying to think of how we met and I
realized that it was through your
students yeah they have to say they're
very persistent I got an email saying
what I like to speak at their class and
I say oh not really oh but I couldn't
actually say no so I said I'm busy get
back in about three years and and they
got back and wouldn't let me off the
hook and I'm so glad that they didn't
because we now have a relationship and I
really do value that thank you for that
I do have a PowerPoint I'm really
thinking I might not use it what do you
thinks I use a PowerPoint who wants me
to use a PowerPoint who doesn't want me
use a PowerPoint
I think they want me to use a PowerPoint
but i'm not going to it it's your
PowerPoint you can do whatever you want
with it if you put it on ebay just think
of me okay just think of me I'm going to
make four points in my remarks point
number one the economic recovery and we
are in a recovery the recovery began
nearly a year and a half ago has lost a
significant amount of momentum so let me
give you a number to give some meat to
that GDP the value of all the things
that we produce grew three-point-three
percent analyzed in the second half of
2009 two-point-seven percent in the
first half of 2010 in the second half of
this year the current period we're now
growing about two percent annualized
just to give you context the economy's
potential rate of growth that rate of
growth consistent with a stable rate of
unemployment is between two and a half
and three percent so we're not growing
fast enough to create enough jobs to
even keep the unemployment rate at its
current nine point six percent the
unemployment rate will rise and I would
not be surprised if it were to rise back
into double digits by early 2011 Spring
of 2011 the slowdown in the economy that
we've experienced isn't totally
unexpected the economy early in the
recovery was supported by temporary
factors the most notable in a factor
that's generated a great deal of debate
is the fiscal stimulus in my mind the
fiscal stimulus did precisely what it
was intended to do it was designed to
end the Great Recession and begin an
economic recovery and that's exactly
what happened the maximum benefit from
this fiscal stimulus took place in June
of 2009
and that is the precise month in which
the stimulus in which the recession
ended according to the National Bureau
of Economic Research now of course the
stimulus was never intended to be a
source of long-term economic growth and
it now is beginning to fade we went from
no stimulus to a lot of stimulus and
that helped to juice up economic
activity and now we're going back to no
stimulus and in that process the economy
is beginning to slow that should be no
surprise anyone into policy makers of
Congress the administration don't come
forward with any additional stimulus at
this point in the wake of the midterm
elections that seems unlikely then the
stimulus will actually become a drag on
economic activity as we make our way
into next year but that's no fault of
the stimulus the stimulus did precisely
what was intended it ended the recession
it jump-started an economic recovery but
it was a temporary source approach I
will have to say however that the
slowdown in economic growth that we've
experienced since the beginning of the
year is more significant than I would
have anticipated so if I were here six
months ago and we were talking about the
latter half of 2010 I would have argued
that the economy would still be
struggling to grow but not to the degree
that it is and I think the reason for
this surprising slowdown in economic
activity is the European sovereign-debt
crisis that was a surprise to me came
out of nowhere from my perspective at
least the virulence of it did back in
the spring and the link between the
European sovereign-debt situation in our
economy is the equity market usually the
causality between the equity market and
stock market of the economy run in both
directions and it still does but it
feels to me like the causality is very
powerfully moving from the equity market
to the economy more so than any time in
the past businesses are using the equity
market as a signal with respect to
whether they should go out invest
higher and perhaps more importantly
high-income households are very attuned
to their balance sheet because their
nest eggs have been significantly
diminished by what we've been through
they're very sensitive to any changes in
that balance sheet in their net worth
and change in stock values and moreover
enhancing this relationship between the
stock market economy is that we all we
are all getting a lot older now here's
the most important statistic of the day
in fact be shine I'm going to ask you
what is the largest single year age
group in the country there are more of
these folks than any other age is it is
it three is it 83 what age is it 45
that's wrong that's wrong that important
see that's spoken like that's truly what
an economist would say 45 to 65 but not
a real estate professional they want
precision they want procedure yeah so
the answer is how old are you buzzed but
by the way Bichon oh that is there you
go I see the answer is 51 51 I i happen
to be 51 I have to do it this is the
teeth of the baby boom generation there
are a lot of 51 year olds 52 50-49 so
forth and so on so if you're 51 years
old and your nest egg is now a third of
what it was or twenty-five percent of
what it was your focus like a laser beam
on your balance sheet because you know
that you don't have a whole lot of time
to get it together the other reason why
this dock market is so important to the
behavior of particularly high income
households and they're very important to
overall consumer spending is that
people's expectations about future asset
price growth have shifted so be Shawn if
I asked you say think back five years
ago in the boom what would be the
average annual growth in
the value of your entire portfolio he
retired the asset side of your balance
sheet how fast do you think that would
it would grow what would you say five
years ago we were in the boom how much a
% v sean is very conservative but
reasonable answer a pension funds would
say eight and a half but you know eight
percent is not bad I think most
Americans probably would have said ten
percent but let's go with eight so now
be Sean you're here today looking
forward 10 years what do you think
average annual asset price growth will
be over the next ten years three percent
so we went from eight percent to three
percent you're 45 I'm 51 what does that
mean that means if there's any shift in
your balance sheet and the value of the
assets you own you become very you're
very quick to respond and so when the
European debt situation hit and took
fifteen percent out of the equity market
that knocked the wind out of the economy
in my view if we had not gotten
sidetracked by the European debt
situation we would all be feeling
measurably better about the economic
situation today the results of the
midterm elections would have been
measurably different but we did get
sidetracked and it didn't cost us the
recovery we're so growing but
nonetheless we're going much more slowly
the recovery is very fragile so point
number one is that we're still growing
we still have recovery but it is that
we've lost a significant amount of
momentum the economy is growing below
its potential point number two how many
points as I say that we're going to be
23 44 points point number two oh by the
way my strategy here is to take you take
you down I'm going to take you low and
then when you're feeling very depressed
I'm going to try to lift you higher I'm
gonna try to look you hard so so bear
with me point number two is now going to
take you down
take you down yeah I know you're down
already I I i should say two things
first of all I run the risk of taking
you too low because I've taken audiences
so far down I can never get them back up
so I'm going to work really hard not to
do that the second thing is I am an
economist you got to keep this in mind
and even when I'm speaking
optimistically it doesn't sound that way
so you have to account for that bias
point number two the next 6-9 perhaps 12
months are going to be very
uncomfortable the economy is not going
to grow fast enough to create enough
jobs to even as I said forestall or
further increase in unemployment
unemployment is likely to rise we're
going back into double digits by early
next year I don't think we're going to
double dip but the odds of double
dipping are uncomfortably high
uncomfortably high let me give you
there's a there's a multitude of reasons
for this nervousness but because I don't
want to take you too low i'm not going
to go through them i'm sure in the QA
the person who's very dark in the room
will drag us down further by pointing
out that I failed to mention one of
these problems that we have but I'm
going to focus on two problems two
problems then I'm most nervous about in
the next six to nine months perhaps 12
months the first is that going back to
the job market while businesses are no
longer laying off in any significant way
the rate of layoffs are back to where
you would normally expect them in a
reasonably well functioning economy the
hiring is just not there businesses are
not hiring let me give you a statistic
to flesh that out prior to the recession
if you go back 20 50 60 seven month Lee
hires are running somewhere between five
and five and a half million per month in
the recession hire slid they bottomed
out around four million hires per month
and we've been at four million per month
since then no change if we're going to
get the kind of job growth we're going
to need
to sustain just a stable rate of
unemployment we're going to get back
closer to five million and if we want
job growth its sufficient to bring down
unemployment in the significant way
we're going to have to get up closer to
five and a half million we're a long way
from that and while it's difficult to
put your finger on exactly what's wrong
let me mention a couple of things that I
think are really bothering businesses
the first thing is a lack of credit not
for big companies not for midsize
companies but for small businesses
here's a key statistic establishments
that employ fewer than 100 workers
account for half of all of the jobs in
the economy and two-thirds of the net
job creation and last economic expansion
it's small businesses can't get credit
they can't hire and if they can't hire
the job machine can't get going and
small businesses are still having a
great deal of difficulty going down to
their friendly bank and getting that
loan that they need to go out and expand
their operations to make that investment
into the dire somebody another reason
for the lack of hiring is confidence
we're all very nervous we've been
through a lot the great recession was
gut-wrenching I don't think any business
person forgets that very quickly I mean
I was a small business person I started
my company back in nineteen ninety i
sold i sold it to the moody's
corporation about five years ago but i
was a small business owner for 15 years
and i went through two recessions and
they were mild recessions and it took me
a long time to get over it and then I
can't imagine as a small business person
operating in today's environment for
getting what they went through or what
they're still going through very quickly
so it's just going to take time the
other reason why confidence is so weak
however is in this is my view it's very
difficult to document but it's my sense
of it talking to business people across
the country is policy uncertainty you
know we have made some very epic policy
decisions health care reform financial
regulatory reform we've been debating
energy policy we've been debating
immigration policy we still don't know
what our tax rates are going to be on
january first so reason number one for
some nervousness about
economic recovery over the next six to
nine perhaps 12 months is the lack of
hiring today was going to mention to two
things to be nervous about the second
thing is the foreclosure crisis that is
ongoing that has not ended another
statistic there are 4.1 million first
mortgage loans that are in default or
headed in that direction 90 days and
over delinquent there are 49 million
first mortgage loans outstanding so
eight percent of mortgage loans are in
this predicament that means some parts
of the country it's measurably worse in
Florida one in five mortgages are in
default or close to in Miami the default
rate is close to close to one in three
now I would expect that a fair share of
the 4.1 million loans that are in
default status our clothes will get some
form of modification the administration
has a modification plan private mortgage
company the mortgage companies have
their own private mod plans in place
generously speaking I would anticipate a
couple million modifications that will
occur but that still leaves 2 million
plus loans that will go through the
foreclosure process to a distress sale
to a foreclosure or shortsale and the
key statistic with respect to housing
values to share of home sales that are
distressed if that share is rising house
prices are going to fall and it's now
very very likely that we're going to see
more house price declines over the
course of the next six nine 12 months
nothing really works in our economy if
house prices are falling the home is
still the most important asset in most
people's balance sheet going back to my
earlier point about the sensitivity that
people have to their their net worth and
again going back to small businesses
most small businesses use their home as
collateral when getting alone and again
I can testify to this to testify to this
personally as I said I started my
company in 1990 with my brother and one
other fellow and by 1993 we decided that
we wanted to go out and expand but you
know we didn't have any cash that we
needed to get a business loan so i went
down to my friendly bank the bank that I
had been depositing our meager
somes into and they they quickly turned
us down they quickly turns down and then
I went to my really friendly bank the
community bank malvern federal savings
bank which is still with us and doing
quite well thank you I pay back my loan
they gave me alone now of course when I
signed when I got the loan I had to sign
a stack of papers about that high in one
part of the stack was me signing away
lily to the bank and the other was
signing away my home to the bank now I
don't think my wife really understood
she had to sign to of course I'm not
sure she really understood what she was
signing it all worked out in the end but
nonetheless it was pretty nerve-wracking
but what's my point my point is that
many small business people across the
country use their homes or their
commercial real estate as collateral to
get that small business loan if housing
values of commercial real estate values
are uncertain or under pressure they're
not going to be able to do that they're
not going to be able to get that loan
and the job if she's not going to be
able to get going another reason for
some concern how you feeling
low depressed I succeeded okay that's
the conclusion of point number 2 i'm now
going to proceed to lift you higher
point number three I forgot point in
Missouri no way kid point number three
we will make it through the next six to
nine months without going into recession
and this time next year when you all
meet the economy is going to be feeling
measurably better and when you meet two
years from now the economy is going to
be off and running off and running that
may give you a few reasons for this
optimism and by the way i should say
just one caveat i am well outside the
consensus here if you ask most
economists what they think about the
next few years they'll say we're going
to get three percent gdp growth per
annum ad infinitum into the future which
by the way if that's true that means
we're going to have unemployment close
to ten percent forever ad infinitum the
future I don't believe it in fact i
think gdp growth will be two and a three
percent in 2010 it will be 2 923 percent
in 2011 to my second point but by 2012 I
think we gdp growth of five percent 2013
five percent very very strong growth
here are the reasons for this
perspective reason number one this is a
very near term reason the Federal
Reserve is going to do everything it
takes to make sure that we don't go back
into recession that is the most
important message in the revival
quantitative easing Federal Reserve is
now going out is announced its going to
buy a boatload of Treasury securities
and this will only be the beginning if
it doesn't work I think it will work it
already is working stock prices are up
fixed mortgage rates are at record lows
inflation expectations have firm the
value of the dollar is fallen very
modestly but still very helpful too
me the Federal Reserve has gotten
exactly what it wanted and it will do
more if necessary the Federal Reserve
knows that the risks to the economic
expansion and recovery are quite high
they know if we go back into recession
it's going to be very difficult to get
out there is no policy response they
know in the wake of the midterm
elections that there will be no
additional fiscal stimulus it is on them
and they are up to the task and they
will do what's necessary now I'm sure
they're very very surprised at the
vitriol that it's been swung their way
here domestically and more importantly
overseas but in my view that is
misplaced that what they're doing is
precisely the appropriate thing for our
country and for the entire global
economy because the US economy is still
twenty five percent of global gdp and if
we're not growing no one's grown and we
need to do what's right for our economy
and that is keeping interest rates down
and keep stock prices up and that'll
keep this economy moving forward and I
think the Federal Reserve will continue
on that path until it's absolutely
they're absolutely sure that we're
creating enough growth and jobs so that
unemployment comes down in a meaningful
way so that's reason number one for
optimism my faith in the ability and
willingness of the Federal Reserve to do
what is necessary to make sure that we
don't backtrack reason number two this
is more fundamental pick any economic
statistic you want take a look at GDP
take a look at jobs take a little retail
sales look at industrial production
anything you want them each one of those
statistics is still measurably below
where it was at the start of the
economic recession except there is one
statistic that is all the way back from
the bottom it's even higher today than
it was prior to the recession anyone
want to venture a guess what that
statistic is yes sir
productivity and that's that's true very
true and what is what's the benefit of
productivity where does that where's the
benefits of that go where has it gone so
far corporate profits right corporate
earnings right so corporate profits are
back higher than they were prior to the
economic recession now the growth and
corporate earnings is the result of
significant cost cutting now all those
lost jobs clearly extraordinarily
painful it's going to take years to get
all those people back employed but the
benefit of that and there is has been a
benefit is that has resulted in
tremendously wide margins for businesses
you take those margins you mix in a
little bit of sales growth and you get
tremendous earnings growth and right now
corporate earnings economy-wide big
companies midsize companies and even
small companies is growing forty fifty
percent year-over-year now admittedly
against easy comparison but nonetheless
that's about as strong corporate
earnings picture as we've seen since
World War two in the data that we have
back to World War two corporate balance
sheets are in excellent shape if you
look at any measure of corporate help
financial health interest coverage
ratios you look at cash on balance
sheets quick ratios we've never seen
anything that comes close to how strong
corporate balance sheets are strong
profits strong balance sheets it's no
longer in my mind a question of can
businesses expand they can't it's really
a question of are they willing it's a
matter of confidence and that is a very
important distinction very the necessary
condition for a much better economy is
firmly in place we just need to get a
little bit of confidence and deploying
those resources in fact here's a
intrepid forecast for you a year from
now a light switch is going to go on in
corporate America they're going to say
to themselves you know what one CEO and
each industry is going to save
themselves you know what I can't
continue to grow earnings by cutting
costs I've done that I've gotten all the
pro the productivity gains the mask
that I can the only way I'm going to
grow earnings if I take a chance I go
out and I invest and I hire and by the
way I'm not going to be able to maintain
that stock price unless I maintain the
earnings growth and once one CEO and
each industry decides to turn on the
light switch we're going to see CEOs
while all CEOs follow suit and we're
going to go from 75,000 80,000 and
monthly job growth to 150,000 200,000
250,000 300,000 a monthly job growth and
it's going to happen almost literally
overnight we're going to be surprised
how quickly that occurs so reason number
two for optimism is that corporate
America is very very strong very strong
reason number how you feeling better
right I knew the corporate earnings
thing would really get you going yeah i
was giving this speech in des moines it
wouldn't really resonate as well but i
know here in this room that would work
reason number three / optimism would you
mind if I take my jacket off it's very
high is it okay I noticed you guys are
all very formal but is that okay I
noticed bichon no matter how
uncomfortable he was he wasn't going to
take off his yeah I'm taking this off
though ladies going to say dad how could
you do that match is going to say dad
how could you say that where was I Oh
reason number three for optimism we are
righting the wrongs that got us into
this mess the most fundamental reason
for this mess we're in are the millions
of bad loans we made in the boom in the
bubble and we're well on our way to
working through those owns we still have
a foreclosure crisis we still have a
couple million first mortgage loans to
work through but we've worked through
two-thirds of the problem loans that
were out there at the beginning of the
of the economic crisis and the de
leveraging process that households are
now going through the reduction in their
debt which is a significant weight on
consumer spending will come to an end
about this time next
here the key statistic for determining
the end of household deleveraging is the
household debt service burden the
proportion of after-tax income that
households must devote to their interest
in principal payments to remain current
on their debt at the current rate of
deleveraging if that occurs for one more
year the de leveraging that occurred
over the past year occurs for one more
year in interest rates remain where they
are which is a reasonably good bet then
a year from now the household debt
service burn will be near a record low
and if the leveraging continues for
another year and a half interest rates
remaining that where they are a year and
a half from now the debt service burden
will be indeed at a record low at that
point in time in my view the
deleveraging process will come to an end
will go from massive reductions in debt
I'm not arguing that we're going to get
significant increases in credit people
aren't going to go out and borrow
aggressively again but simply going from
significant declines in what a delay in
debt deleveraging to know deleveraging
is the lifting of a significant weight
on consumer spending on an economic
activity and that's going to happen just
about this time next year into early
2012 one more reason for optimism the
level of economic activity as I've
alluded to earlier is incredibly low
relative to any demographic households
population age composition of the
population and at some point we're going
to see a significant unleashing of what
is developing what i would call that's
developing is called pent-up demand so
let me illustrate this point in the case
of the vehicle market the view we're
selling vehicles at an annualized rate
of about eleven and a half million units
in a normal well functioning economy if
everything was functioning appropriately
we would be selling somewhere between 15
and a half to 16 million units so right
now we're selling it well below trend
understandably so the problems the job
market the lack of credit the lack of
confidence but as soon as we get a
little bit of job growth a little bit of
credit and a little bit of confidence
we're going to see a significant pick up
in
vehicle sales go back closer to the
demographic trend and then probably
beyond that people are pulling back on
their purchases the demographically
would like to buy theirs their families
are growing and aging and they would
like to go out and purchase things
historically they have but they're not
doing that now because they're nervous
but once they're more confident they're
going to step up and go out and spend a
lot more we're going to see a lot of
economic activity generated by this
unleashing of pent up demand in the
vehicle market through other kinds of
consumer durables and even in the
housing market even the hounds barking
so reason number four for optimism is
the fact that the level of economic
activity is very very low relative to
any measure of demographics and
demographics don't mean a whole lot in
any given year but they mean everything
over periods of three to five to ten
years they are very very important to
economic growth and they're on our side
how you feeling now a little bit better
okay point number four the last point
Ellen here for my optimism to come to
pass there are a number of working
assumptions that have to hold in fact
there are a fair number of forking
assumptions that after all I'm not going
to go through them but I'm going to
mention too because they're very
important the first working assumption
is that our economy broadly as to make a
graceful transition away from a
consumer-led economy to an economy
that's led by exports and business
investment that high-income households
they're focused on their net worth they
know they don't have much time before
retirement they can see that the fiscal
commission is trying to scale back
Social Security and looking the
retirement age and they need to save
more lower middle-income households they
can no longer borrow like they did
because of the situation that we're in
they can no longer borrow and spend
beyond your
come they can no longer dis say
consumers have been the engine of global
economic growth in 25 years they've loud
they're saving rate to decline steadily
throughout that period the Great
Recession the period we've just gone
through is an inflection point for the
US consumer the consumer will continue
to spend but will not spend beyond their
income they'll spend less than their
income saving rates will rise if this is
the case then if we're going to enjoy
the kind of growth rates that we have
experienced historically we need another
source of growth and that source of
growth in my view is selling what we
produce to the rest of the world exports
and then investing here in the United
States to be able to produce the things
to export to the rest of the world and
if you're an American company that
survived what we went through then you
must be doing something right you have
to have a market niche you have to have
a very competitive cost structure and we
do many things right we export many
things very successfully and we will
continue to do that aerospace computer
technologies software sophisticated
instrumentation materials
pharmaceuticals agricultural products
processed foods and also going forward
we're going to export things that we've
been doing for many many years long
before anyone else on the planet and we
do them really really well services
architectural services engineering
service management consulting services
yes financial services financial
services legal services economic
consulting services right I make models
that the European banks are using in
their stress test I produce those models
in suburban Philadelphia because it's
the best place to find the most
qualified people to produce those models
for the rest of Bank of China uses my
models I wish they would use them more
but you know they are using
services embody our comparative
advantage as a nation are educated and
skilled workforce that is what makes
this country great it's our people in
services embody the best and the
brightest and we are going to do we've
been doing it for years we will continue
to do it and we're going to sell those
things to the rest of the world and it's
going to drive employment and economic
growth long into the future this is a
working assumption this has to happen in
a reasonably graceful way we have to
make this transition working assumption
number two and here all end and this
this is an assumption you may not buy
into but I'm going to try my best anyone
want to take guess that would be working
assumption number two is it's the
elephant the big elephant in the room
it's our fiscal situation right in my
view policy makers had no choice and how
they responded to the financial crisis
in the Great Recession you can take
exception to any individual aspect of
the response but the total totality of
the economic response was in my mind
incredible it was unprecedented and it
worked if they had not done what they
did we would be in a measurably worse
place today now as they say in economics
there is no such thing as a free lunch
it cost us right the fiscal stimulus
when you add it all up is 1.1 trillion
dollars the budget deficit in fiscal
year 09 was 1.4 trillion the fiscal year
2010 budget deficit was one-point-three
percent nine percent of GDP our problems
are very serious we have to address them
we have to address them but I'm here to
say that I think we will we will the key
reason couple q reasons for this
optimism one is our problems are not as
serious as we think they're serious but
they're not overwhelmed let me give you
some let me do some arithmetic for you
in fiscal year 2010 the 1.3 trillion
dollar budget deficit was nine percent
of GDP in a reasonably well functioning
me the budget deficit the sickly
so-called cyclically adjusted budget
deficit is five percent of GDP we're
going to go from nine percent to five
percent over the next couple three years
if my script holds in any reasonable way
fiscally sustainable budget deficit that
deficit that we need to get to to be
sustainable so that we can make our
interest payments so that they don't
balloon out and swamp us it's three
percent of GDP we need to go from five
percent of GDP to three percent that's a
2 percentage-point gap right to put that
in dollar terms that's 300 billion
dollars per year right now we have to
close the 300 billion dollar budget yet
now that's a big number but that's
doable that's doable now just for
context Iran and Afghanistan are costing
is 100 billion dollars a year now as a
prudent be recruited budgeter you would
assume we're going to spend under
billion dollars forever in Afghanistan
and Iraq but you know maybe we got lucky
at some point in time but nonetheless
just for context so how are going to
close that gap well the fiscally
chairman the two chairmen of the
bipartisan fiscal commission reported
out yesterday and their proposal on how
to close the gap and you know what they
have it pretty much just right we need
spending restraint and we need tax cuts
on the tax side we need to focus on the
tax deductions mortgage interest comes
to mind pretty quickly and on the
spending side we need to focus on
medical care costs and social security
and I think in fact when it's all said
and done that's precisely what we're
going to do we're going to close that
300 billion dollar gap by focusing on
those simple things it's not going to
happen in 2012 2011 or 2012 but in the
next presidential term I think we're
going to find the political will to do
it in one final point we don't need the
United States does not need to close its
budget gap that's 300 billion dollar
budget gap in one year we're not crazy
we don't need to close it in three to
five years we're not France or Germany
we're the United States of America and
we have latitude because every time
we've gotten into difficult in we have
gotten many times in the past difficulty
we have always figured a way out and
global investors know that if there's a
problem anywhere on the planet including
in the United States global investors
come to the United States where else can
you were buying a 10-year treasury bond
at two and a percent and even if the Fed
didn't have your back will be three or
three and a half percent we have time we
don't have to close a three hundred
billion dollar budget hole in one year
three years or five years we've got five
to ten years that's thirty sixty billion
dollars a year that is very doable we
can do that without affecting our
long-term economic growth prospects and
we will be just fine we will be just
fine how's that for an uplifting ending
who Shaun is saying to himself thank
goodness he didn't use the power point I
took off my jacket test for you thank
you I it's amazing you know there's a I
love what's that two guys without a
jacket there's an incredibly intelligent
but slight geekish pneus that i just
thought i'd really appreciate you smell
like a kike this is this is Columbia
University's so do we have some
questions for doctors Andy dan doctoroff
this is a plan by the way it's a plan
but we don't know what's gonna happen we
don't know it's bad right yeah you want
to know about the Yankees why didn't
they are you Yankees fan yeah whining
that winner will series I really want to
why the Phillies you know yeah so here's
my question my question is in you spoke
for let's say 25 minutes might have been
a few minutes longer can only imagine
what it would have been if you had the
power point but no in that entire time
you did not mention the word Obama once
so my question to you is is the
president now irrelevant and if not
what's the one thing that you think over
the course of the next year 22 that he
realistically could do that would affect
things in a positive way
for me I am said I'm the geekiest part
is taking over I'm trying to formulate
my response I'll respond in two ways
first is I do not think that there will
be any major economic policy made in the
next two years that from that
perspective I would say that the
administration is irrelevant yes that in
the wake of the midterm elections the
political environment is shifted to the
degree that I think it will be very
difficult to do anything of major
consequence the only the only reason I
would be wrong in that statement is if
things go badly wrong if we start going
south nothing crystallizes the thinking
of even a tea party member than losing
the election and they would if the
economy goes south so that would
jumpstart some policy making but other
than that if the economy sticks roughly
to the script I laid out I don't see any
significant economic policymaker now i
will say tangentially that there is an
upside to that in the context of my
policy argument about policy uncertainty
i do think there is some advantages to
having a policy timeout so that we can
cross the t's and dot the i's on health
care reform and financial regulatory
reform nail down the tax code and
provide that clarity that businesses
people need to go out and start to
expand into to invest so you know I
don't think it's the fact that we're not
gonna have any major economic policy you
know it does make me a bit nervous in
the context of the risks that we face
but it does have some advantages that
could could help support the recovery
going forward now having said that if
the second really the second part of
your question is what could he do that
would be of substance going forward in
my view
it would be if he was very courageous
and took a step outside of his own party
and led the way let me give you a case
in point George Bush number one the
president 1990 said I'm not going to
raise taxes his no no read my lips
pledge and he broke that pledge she
raised taxes and in my view that
courageous event led led the way and
grew laid the groundwork for a decade of
fiscal restraint discipline that led to
a budget surplus by the end of the
decade now clearly President Clinton
followed on he was courageous in his own
way and followed through with President
Bush but President Bush gave up his
second term in many respects because he
did that and I think if President Obama
did the same thing it took that chance
he may very well well win the election
because in my view the economy in 2012
is going to be very different than the
economy in 1992 the economy is going to
be a heads back it's not going to be in
his face as it was this year or was as
it was in 1992 but if he took that
chance it would really lay the
groundwork for him doing something very
substantive in actually hitting my bogey
in 2013 and doing in making those
changes that I think we need to make and
in fact I'll say this I didn't mention
President Obama but I think he's up to
it and I think in fact he will we'll go
down that path that he will do something
that is outside the box for him and for
his party and that will lead the way and
show the we need a leader we need
leadership now and that will be the
leadership will need to really make the
changes and get to the optimistic
outlook that I particularly
and if he does that I'm going to I'll
certainly help mr. Bloomberg but I will
certainly also help mr. Obama because
that would take a great act of courage
hey one or two more questions oh right
over here yes sir you stand up who are
you by the way
are you a plant yes yes what's the role
of net exporting countries and their
future investment United States and just
I like China for instance is receiving a
lot of US dollars through trade where
will they reinvest those dollars and how
will we see that here locally so so the
question is how will mostly emerging
economies that are running relatively
large current account surpluses how will
they invest those funds in the United
States and historically in the case of
China in particular they began buying
Treasury bonds right and then they moved
on to buying mortgage securities and in
some respects the fodder for the great
for the financial panic all those bad
loans we made the financial crisis the
Great Recession was the flood of cash
that was coming into the United States
because of China was in a number of
emerging other emerging economies were
coming onto the scene and they were
investing very aggressively and our
fixed incomes it's fixed income
securities and to Treasury bonds driving
interest rates down and driving up
housing demand and also into mortgage
securities I think over time they become
much more they become much more
sophisticated investors and they've been
looking for higher returns you know
obviously with current yields they need
in Treasury and other fixed in less
risky fixed-income assets we're looking
for a greater returns elsewhere so I
think they have an increasing appetite
for equity real estate real investment
in companies and assets art assets and I
think we should expect them and we
should welcome their investment in all
of those kinds of asset classes in fact
in my view we should do everything we
can possibly do to foster that because
the closer were tethered at the hip the
more likely that our interests are going
to be aligned and the less likely we're
going to start debating each other about
the value of the currency and other
issues that are just sidebars and start
worrying about how to make both our
population
you know stronger and richer and more
wealthy so I think it would be very
counterproductive to erect any barriers
we should welcome that investment and
embrace it because I think that'll make
both our economies in the global economy
measurably stronger did I answer your
question not really you want to know if
they're going to buy your apartment
building is that the question is will
this be a play a role in the economic
recovery you know I don't view this as a
is a something that matters any
significant degree and you give a
quarter or even even a year this is
something that's going to play out over
a long period of time that you know
their their investments are evolving
over time it's going to be years decades
you know kind of process not it doesn't
make a big difference i don't think in
in the next six nine twelve months
certainly i don't think i'm going to
pull out of their investments to the
degree that would be disruptive that
would be very counterproductive because
they're already pretty closely tethered
to us at this point are we getting tired
well I mean use directors progress fast
last question was there any truth to my
reckless assertion that denser urban
areas will are actually going to fare
better you know I was thinking about
that I I have to think about that some
more I mean it's intriguing idea it
makes sense intuitive sense but I can i
reserve an opinion all right wait for
the analysis yeah I think it said but I
think we should probably let class out
thank you wanting the pleasure thank you
thank you very much
you